Whitebeard
Even in death, even with half of his head
blown clean away, his body refuses to yield.
His mighty figure, cutting swathes through
his foes, was truly monstrous.
Over the course of his battles he received
a full 267 blade wounds, the bullets he endured
total 152, and the cannonballs he has withstood
amount to 46.
And yet, upon the proud back of this legendary
man, or indeed upon his very life as a pirate,
he bears no single wound of cowardice.
If you wanna find an example of a truly - perfect
supporting character, you need look no further
than Edward Newgate aka Whitebeard and his
role in the story of One Piece.
Oda does a wonderful job of making him one
of THE most badass and influential characters
in the series.
And he does it in a very interesting way.
He introduces Whitebeard as the STRONGEST
pirate in the series, while at the same time
utilising every SINGLE aspect of his character
as a powerful storytelling device.
As you might know, many supporting characters
in your average story usually serve at least
one of two purposes: Make them interact with
the main character so we can engage with them
and thus advance the story, or supply us with
some new piece of information about the world
our story takes place in.
With Whitebeard, Oda does both.
He uses the Emperor to VASTLY expand our understanding
of the one piece world and sets the stage
for the second half of the plot in the new
world.
And at the SAME time, Oda also fleshes out
his character to be one of THE most important
and powerful players in the story.
And I believe that this - was a really smart
move.
Because what makes Whitebeard SO popular and
exciting as a character, at least on the surface,
is not what he teaches us about the world,
but who he is as a person.
The strongest man alive.
The pirate respected and feared by all.
And the man who went head to head with the
world government by starting the war of the
best.
And so I think it’s more than adequate that
in THIS video we will be discussing not one,
but TWO aspects of Whitebeard’s character:
How he drastically expanded our view of the
One Piece world and why he was the next unofficial
Pirate king after Gol D. Roger.
Before I go and explain how INGENIOUSLY Oda
has used Whitebeard as a world building element
and how CRITICAL he was in setting up the
second half of the story, I think I first
have to justify myself for saying that Whitebeard
was the second pirate king.
That’s a pretty bold statement after all
- believe me, I know.
But if you bear with me here, I promise it
will ALL make sense once we make it to the
end of this video.
So let’s start from zero and steadily build
our way towards pirate king material.
Because, to TRULY understand Whitebeard’s
character, we first have to understand the
underlying THEME around which Oda has created
his design.
Idealism.
If I made you forget EVERYTHING you knew about
Edward Newgate and his actions in the story,
and THEN asked you to think about what the
IDEAL pirate in one piece for you would look
like, I bet most people would come up with
either one of two categories: Power or personality.
After all what sets Luffy apart from other
characters in the story are pretty much these
2 things.
There are many characters that are as compassionate
and strong-willed as Luffy, and there are
just as many characters that are as strong
or even stronger than him.
And so in the end, what REALLY makes Luffy
so unique, is that he is both.
However, while Luffy still has to grow as
a person over the course of the story and
has to train to become stronger, with Whitebeard
Oda shows us what an ideal candidate for pirate
king should look like in the end.
I STRONGLY believe, that he’s the ULTIMATE
role model in terms of strength and character
for Luffy to follow.
So let’s look in detail at how Oda created
Whitebeard within these 2 categories.
When Whitebeard was first introduced way back
in chapter 234, Oda gave him the epithet of
strongest man in the world for a reason.
While I think it’s fair to debate whether
he was actually stronger than Roger, whether
Kaido as the strongest creature in the world
might have been even more powerful and whether
he was already beyond his prime at Marineford,
I think what isn’t up for debate is that
for at least two DECADES, Edward Newgate was
the most powerful human in the one piece world,
PERIOD.
On the most basic level, this was of course
due to his enormous physical strength - equipped
with powerful Haki and of course due to his
powerful devil fruit, the Gura-Gura no mi,
that is said to hold the power to destroy
the entire world.
In ALL the encounters he has at marineford,
whether it be Akainu or Blackbeard, he always
seems to have the edge, despite his countless
wounds and illnesses.
And of course, we could witness his true power
in his clashes with Oden and Roger, both of
which were considered to be monsters themselves
in terms of brute strength.
Additionally, he was a MORE than capable swordsman,
wielding one of the 12 supreme Meito swords,
that he most likely turned into a black blade
over his lifetime.
But beyond these monstrous physical abilities,
Whitebeard also held enormous TACTICAL power.
As one of the Yonko, he commanded an enormous
crew and an even larger fleet of affiliated
pirates.
Especially after Roger’s execution and the
end of their rivalry, Whitebeard, who also
had the second highest BOUNTY after Roger,
used his personal AND military power - and
in combination with a very sharp and tactical
mind - to ultimately be the one to control
large parts of the oceans and to keep the
balance in the new world.
Just HOW strong his grip on the world actually
was, became especially clear after the war,
where as a result of his death the balance
of the world was dealt a devastating blow.
Countless islands under his protection fell
into anarchy and were invaded by other pirates,
and the power vacuum he left behind gave room
for new players to gain influence in the new
world, including the likes of Luffy and Blackbeard.
"Only the strong chose how they die; weaklings
don't have that right."
And speaking of Whitebeard’s legacy, his
death at Marineford, in my opinion, might
be one of THE most misunderstood scenes in
the entire story.
Many people like to accuse Whitebeard of not
being the man he once was at Marineford and
as a result badly overestimating his own strength.
However, as I see it, Oda made it pretty much
clear, that he never had the intention of
surviving the war in the first place.
Instead, it should be his ultimate proof of
pride and power.
In other words: Whitebeard went to Marineford
- to die.
He purposefully removed the medication he
was hooked to, that was keeping him alive.
He joined the fight heads on, WITHOUT any
regard for his health or his life to prove
to the world that he could STILL fight with
the big shots.
The thing Whitebeard feared the most was being
pitied for his condition, and so he decided
that he’d rather go out with a bang rather
than slowly waste away on board of his ship.
His true intention for the war then, was to
free Ace and make him his successor and the
top candidate for the next pirate king.
This, in my opinion, is one of the strongest
displays of honour, strength and will we have
seen in all of one piece outside of the straw
hats.
Another point I think is important to make
when considering Oda’s portrayal of Whitebeard,
is his source inspiration for the character.
Primarily, there are TWO major characters
who’s attributes have been united in the
Emperor.
The first is the real life Blackbeard.
His character has been an inspiration for
both, White- AND Blackbeard, for two reasons.
First his name, Edward Teach, which Oda has
split into Edward Newgate and Marshall D.
Teach.
And secondly, his reputation as one of the
most infamous real pirates in our world.
What this shows us, is that Oda has actively
chosen the most recognisable example of a
true pirate as the basis for Whitebeard’s
character.
But there is second figure, this time from
Japanese folklore, that also plays a major
role here.
I’m speaking of the character of Benkei,
a legendary Japanese warrior monk who was
said to have lived in the latter years of
the Heian Period in the 12th century.
Benkei was notoriously known for his superhuman
strength as well as his strong sense of loyalty.
The monk was said to be at least five TIMES
the size of a normal man and wielded a naginata
as his weapon of choice, the same long-range
type of blade as Murakumogiri, the blade that
Whitebeard wields.
However, the deed Benkei is MOST known for
is dying against an overwhelming force of
enemies, standing upright and riddled by arrows
and spears.
Oda chose these obvious parallels for a reason.
They are what make Whitebeard into the proud,
strong and fearless pirate that he is.
Only HE, being Roger’s equal, would have
been able to start a second era of piracy.
Because to become pirate king, one needs to
be a true ideal of strength and power.
Now, while will-power, strength and influence
are certainly basic requirements for becoming
pirate king, there are actually a number of
candidates that fall into this category, that
literally nobody would want to see on top
of the food chain.
Except for Ryan.
What the hell’s wrong with you Ryan?
So what makes Roger or Luffy different from
say a Blackbeard or a Kaido?
I would argue that it’s compassion and kindness
that makes for an ideal pirate king, at least
in my and probably also in Oda’s eyes.
Both, Roger and Luffy represent the quote-unquote
good pirate that helps the weak and strives
for justice, freedom and happiness.
And that’s what sets them apart from other
strong characters in One Piece.
And therefore, I think this also serves as
an argument that Whitebeard also held the
unofficial role of pirate king, as he is not
only an ideal of power and strength but also
of compassion and kindness.
While he easily could have reached Laugh tale
as well, he never cared to find the one piece
in the first place.
What Newgate was actually looking for was
to form strong relationships and find the
family that he was denied as a child, growing
up as an orphan.
While we do not know yet, what he was like
during his time with the Rocks pirates, at
least by the time he started his own crew,
he was a cheerful and carefree young pirate,
roaming the seas.
His primary mission in life was protecting
the weak.
And he did so by putting entire ISLANDS under
his flag and by recruiting lost men into his
crew by adopting them as his sons.
He did so with Squard, who lost his entire
crew to Roger, with Ace, with Blackbeard and
many others, that didn’t have any other
place to go.
He also did not care much for race or status
and was the only one willing to stand up for
the fishmen and end their exploitation through
the humans.
And I think ANOTHER trait that shows whether
someone is a truly great leader is by looking
at how they treat their people.
Compared to many of the other Yonko, Whitebeard
had a truly great crew.
Kaido seems to rule over his men through power
and fear.
Blackbeard has surrounded himself with people
hungry for power and blood.
And Big Mom actually has made her REAL family
into her crew, but doesn’t even get CLOSE
to the level of warmth and joy that the White
Beard Pirates had.
The secret behind this is that Whitebeard
has built his crew predominantly on trust,
love and respect.
Thus, similar to his inspiration Benkei, loyalty
is the major theme of the Whitebeard Pirates,
which is also what makes Blackbeard’s betrayal
of said loyalty the ULTIMATE crime for the
crew.
And something I feel is directly connected
to this idea, is the strong moral code that
Newgate has.
Loyalty & respect are what the Emperor values
most highly.
What makes him different from let’s say
Akainu however, who actually shares surprisingly
similar ideals, is that Whitebeard has the
ability to forgive.
In that sense, the scene with Squard is actually
WAY more important for Whitebeard’s characterisation
than you might have realised.
Despite betraying his trust and loyalty, just
as Blackbeard did, and stabbing him through
the back, Whitebeard forgives him by being
compassionate and understanding his true motivation.
While Blackbeard betrayed him for power, Squard
was manipulated by Akainu into believing that
he would be sacrificed for Ace’s sake.
The fact that Whitebeard is able to distinguish
between these two cases is pretty much the
exact opposite to Akainu’s concept of absolute
justice, which is also, why the conflict between
the two works so wonderfully well.
They in fact do share a number of views and
values, but in the DECISIVE area of morality,
they’re the COMPLETE opposite of each other.
It is also no wonder then, that Whitebeard
quickly grew to enormously respect Luffy,
Oden and Roger, all of which share these two
fundamental traits of strength and compassion
as well and could thus change the world for
the better.
And this is exactly why I believe that while
he never even tried to find the One Piece,
after Roger’s death, Whitebeard effectively
became the next pirate king and ruler of the
seas.
The point here is of course not that Whitebeard
was EXACTLY like Roger, just as Roger was
never exactly like Luffy.
This would not only make little sense, but
would also be extremely boring.
No.
Each of the three has a unique personality
and a unique path to follow.
What unites them however, are these central
traits that Oda presents to us as the requirements
to become the ideal pirate.
Or in other words: the stuff that makes a
Pirate King.
So now that we have dissected how Oda has
created the, in my opinion, FANTASTIC character
of Whitebeard in the context of the story,
in the last part of this video, I wanna explore
how this character ALSO serves as a strong
device for world building.
And what we have discussed so far, hopefully
will help you understand better, what makes
all of this SO genius.
Because in more than just one way, the introduction
of Whitebeard as a CHARACTER - ALSO introduced
to us several crucial aspects of the One piece
world, that were DESPERATELY needed to progress
the plot.
First of all, Whitebeard introduced us to
the old generation.
Through his actions and fights, we were able
to witness the monstrous power that the likes
of Roger, Garp or Rocks must have held when
they were roaming the seas during their prime.
It gives us a sense of WAY greater powers
being at work in the one piece world, than
we originally thought.
Physical and political conflicts suddenly
were on a completely different level.
And this already brings me to my second point:
Setting a new standard.
This new spectrum of strength and influence
that came with Whitebeard and his war against
the Marines was introduced as a new measuring
stick for Luffy and the crew to strive towards.
It showed us how much there still was to learn
and to explore, and how far they still were
from getting even CLOSE to playing at the
top level.
In retrospect, it was Oda basically SHOUTING
at us, that a time skip was coming and that
Luffy needed a significant change in character
AND a new drive to become stronger.
Whitebeard’s death meanwhile rang in the
end of this OLD era and gave rise to the NEW
one, making space for Luffy and others to
grow in.
This of course also included Blackbeard, who’s
character arc in many ways has been about
opposing and ultimately killing off the last
remaining ideal pirate and thus pushing Luffy
to fill this newly created vacuum.
So not only did Whitebeard significantly expand
our understanding of the one piece world,
but he also set up the entirety of the new
world saga by giving the story a fresh start
and at the same time with Blackbeard introducing
the ultimate antagonist for Luffy, that in
more than just one way can be considered the
anti-pirate king that needs to be kept away
from gaining power at all cost.
After all, what we want is an ideal pirate
king.
What we want is someone as worthy for the
title, as the strongest man in the world.
Another character that has had an enormous
impact on Luffy and his journey, is another
Emperor: Shanks.
You can find out what his role in the story
is, and what role nordic mythology plays for
his character, by clicking right here.
Peace guys.